we've had four lead changes and over  time already yeah if I'm Steve Kerr I  got it the ball in the hands of Kevin  Durant especially if he gets a mismatch  Tucker's guarding him now but they like  the mismatch of rivers thaw to run a  screen and roll with that to see if they  can get a little size difference and let  Durant go to work in strips make some  moves once the ball tries to get it says  Jenkins  outside cool  stickers 150-foot what a scramble play  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  watch the ball hit ball 5.5 it'll be  interesting to see on replay  if the rant was out of bounds as he  saved that ball oh how absolutely down  Wow world enemies how do you miss that  that and here's the shot by Steph Curry  Garrett move in jus got by rivers and  knock down the juice well let me see  where the officials are I mean how do  you miss that how do you miss that